welcome back to on base live in your
Bleacher Report app I am Mookie Betts
and today we have Mr Corbin Carroll
what's going on my man how you doing
doing well man you I'm good man thanks
for coming on this show
um you're a fan of the show you then
you've watched uh watched a couple of
episodes yeah yeah thank you for your
support bro thank you now you're on here
and uh all right we'll get into it so
you're the front runner for the Rookie
of the Year right now on Pace for 30 30
season you're bawling doing anything and
everything to help your D-backs win how
is that bro like what's it like like did
you dream of this
yeah I mean um
definitely dreamed of this
um
you know maybe not it coming this early
and and having
um you know some of the successes that
I've had
um
but it's always been definitely the goal
and you know having a success early
especially is
it's good it's awesome right I'm not
gonna say anything negative about that
but sometimes
it
it's kind of It kind of lies to you
right because the game is not that easy
right and then you get humbled you
hadn't really been humbled but you get
humbled at some point right and so how
do you balance like you know that
obviously right
but you don't go expect it you know how
do you balance like not expecting it but
knowing that this game will humble you
no for sure
um you know I feel like there there have
been plenty of tough moments this year
and
um you know I just it feels like
everyone has those stretches and that
it's baseball
um yeah so what gets you through those
stretches but I I think just staying
process oriented is the biggest thing
for me
um taking the result out of it good or
bad and and just
being my own harshest critic like when
things are going good going well
um you know what can I do to continue to
attack my strengths before someone just
attacks them for me and uh you know
when things aren't going as well
um you know just continue to work on the
things that I know make me successful
is the mental therapy side of it is that
by very important to you I mean I'm not
saying it's obviously you wouldn't say
it's not important like do you really
hone in on that
um
you know I'll go I'll do I'll do a
mindfulness session every day
um that's something that I find just
gives me a little bit of peace and uh
you know just the ability to kind of
step out of my own head no I'm gonna do
it right before the game and I feel like
that's what gets me locked in to uh to
just go out there and play with with uh
kind of that piece and that that
clearness of Mind nice yeah all right so
we're gonna let's get into this game
called on base off base
you in and you're out right okay so
are you on base or off base the 2018 Red
Sox
Outfield celebration is better than the
Diamondbacks alcohol celebration for
this year
on base or off base
I might have to be on base with that one
Ah that's my guy I think I got I think
the 2022 D-backs had some better
sellings this year it's it's been
lacking a little bit we gotta step our
game up all right so what you come on
bro what are you gonna do
we started running some football plays
out there you're running football
players Statue of Liberty we got uh what
else you guys got a couple screen
bubbles
okay all right so what about getting
dropped off getting dropped off by your
parents on your first day on base or off
base oh on base of course tell me about
that tell me how because that's cute
that's cute you know like his parents
came dropped him off I guess he was five
going into first grade you know
but
how are you 20 22 22 going into a
is that is that is that in here in
Arizona yeah yeah that was uh what 20
home opener walking in a diamondback
Stadium
giving this mom and dad a hug
that's cute so tell me about that like
how was it in the Jackie Robinson dunks
hello there we go yeah tell me about
that like how was like you know the ride
in were they nervous were you nervous
what was going on was there talking no
they uh so they you know wanted their
big supporters big um you know just
they love watching me live my dream out
and so
um they'd flown down from Seattle
um to watch our home opener this year
and I want to grab them from the airport
and then we swung over to the field then
they want the car to go just do some
chores oh so it wasn't like oh you know
we woke up and said they didn't get your
clothes ready and yeah yeah it wasn't
one of those ah okay uh okay well I mean
it's still cute though you know it's
still cute so what about uh on base off
base bring in an NBA team back to
Seattle
could not be more on this could not be
more on base you're you're NBA guy uh
yeah I mean I grew up going to Sonics
games and you saw KD I did see Katie how
was that like how was that when you
watched KD fresh out of college
I mean I was I was eight so I don't know
if I fully appreciated okay what I was
seeing but uh you know he was you know
dominant right away
um and he was he he was seen Warren
wearing a Corbin Carroll Jersey too yeah
that was that was pretty neat that's
cool right yeah that's how you know you
cold that's how you know you go look at
it there you go right there
yeah I know the sun's have been uh you
know really just real cool to us
um you know have you got to hang out
with any of those guys no but they're
just throughout the games a good amount
of time
um you know there's like a day for one
of the players cam Johnson day oh okay
Chase Field okay I think it was a lost
bet or something yeah okay and uh yeah
but they're out there and they've been
really good to us they they enjoy
watching the games I've seen I've seen
um a
a good amount of time the NBA guys have
come over to uh to watch the game so
what about seeing Barbie and Oppenheimer
in the same back-to-back same day
because that was like a thing right it
was called like barberheimer yeah are
you a barbin high me what what I don't
even know what it would be called but no
I haven't watched either I'm not I'm not
the biggest movie guy oh you know um but
I think that would be a unique day a
memorable day for sure so so you're but
you're off you're off off base is that
just too long in the in the movie
theater or you just don't go to go to
the movie theater yeah but you're you
when you grew up you as you grew up it
was Netflix was already around and Hulu
and man that's crazy
you have to go to Redbox
you only know where red box is no there
was red there that's correct there was
Red Box
that was real young there was uh yeah
see I'm gonna you're gonna hate me for
what's what's the blue and Blockbuster
yeah yeah you don't know about
Blockbusters
you know about Blockbuster okay real
real little man oh real little no I knew
enough to go in there get my games and
come up out of there I knew I knew about
Blockbuster shout out to Blockbuster man
I know you guys are gone now but yo dope
when you're around so let me say this uh
uh I got one more thing
because I've seen that you guys do this
and it's playing board games with your
teammates you're you got to be on base
with that yeah yeah it's so what games
do you guys play because the chess
Checkers chess chess has been the big
one this year yes
um I got the chess board I don't know if
you've seen on Instagram there's a chess
board where you got the pieces and it
lights up and then you pick one up and
they tell you where your moves are I'm
trying to learn chess you have that yeah
I got it we need that yeah we're
terrible but so y'all just we're just
having fun yeah okay not wasting time
but you know just just not so none of
you guys are good at chess we'll throw
we'll throw a couple extra Queens on the
board too trying to even out the game oh
yeah okay all right so so let's keep it
moving man so you're having a great
rookie season you gotta you guys are
young too
how is that looking around and you can
say like I play with a lot of these guys
coming up and this is kind of normal to
me like how how is that yeah I feel like
I feel like that's special
um
so I was drafted in 19 and
um you know I'd say a good group of that
2019 draft
um you know we're playing together on
this stage and then you know you throw
in the alt site in in 2020 and
um kind of a group of minor league
players together there
um
definitely have some some great bonds
with these guys does that do you think
that is a big part of why you guys are
have been so good this year
um you know early late uh you guys have
been great you know been consistent and
obviously every team is going to go
through their ups and downs right yeah
but for
coming in where everyone had you guys
projected and then where you're playing
now this is awesome indeed so do you
feel like
that that plays a part because we we've
been playing together for the last what
a couple years yeah yeah
um I definitely do I think just that
that care you develop for those guys
away from the field
um
you know over the years
um I just I think that pays dividends on
the field and then okay okay so
and you're from Seattle from Seattle
from Seattle and
the All-Star game was in Seattle this
year so tell me about that your first
All-Star Game first of all just hear
about your first All-Star Game how was
it
it was awesome got to hang out with guys
like this guy yeah pretty cool
um you know it was a great mix of like
young exciting players in this league
and then
um also like players that I I grew up
watching and so that was that was a
pretty you know just just cool moment to
be recognized
um you know among players like that and
then it's at home so how many tickets
did you have to leave so I went 21
tickets 21 I heard that was the third
most I think
I heard vladi I heard vladi had oh
nobody had more yeah
um that means he did all that for free
I'm glad yeah he won the Home Run Derby
right yeah yeah he won the homeowners
yeah yeah he ended up being all right
but if he didn't man he did all that for
free he left so 21 tickets and I'm sure
you had a ton of people just that just
came yeah yeah it was a good mix and so
you made the starting lineup
and were you were you nervous at all
well I'm not necessarily nervous but
like anxious you know what what was it
or were you just cool comments no that
that was a little different
um you know just it felt separated from
um you know it didn't necessarily feel
like real baseball I'd say in my mind
um and I think a lot of that was just
you know mandatory
um you know just just guys that have
been there before
um being like hey like just
you gotta have fun you gotta slow down
you gotta enjoy it um and so I really
took that to heart and and just said hey
the game's kind of the least important
thing to me I just want to be around all
these people
um you know soak up their their
knowledge their energy and uh you know
just enjoy it whether whether a good
amount of guys that you gotta go that
you got to talk to to to soak up some
info yeah yeah
um
who who in particular that you give me
one guy in particular that he gave you
some good juice
say I'd say a rise with the ice cream
machine
all right that's where all his hits are
I guess oh yeah all right
okay so him so and he's he's
by the way what he's doing is ridiculous
you know like I that
good for you Louise good for you but
anyways so you also said something to me
that made me feel old
and I asked you you know who here
did you that you're playing with did you
watch growing up and you had said me uh
there had to be someone else Frank
having some I had to be a lot of other
people but you said me and it was super
cool man you know it meant it meant a
lot to me
that you watch me growing up but it made
me feel old man you know I'm 30 and yeah
but you got in young I did get in young
you know what's crazy you signed a
eight-year deal
my Deal's still longer than that like
that's how much that's how much longer
I'm gonna be around here dog so golly
that's ridiculous but anyways
who else did you grow up watching
that you got to play with because that's
not a lot of people I I can say I got to
play with Jeter you know I got to play a
couple games of Jeter and that is the
person that I was kind of shaking when I
met him and so who was kind of like that
for you that you got to play with yeah I
mean I mean the big guys were obviously
um you know trout and Harper
um
but neither of them were there this year
um you know
um
judge
yeah yeah let's choose another yeah okay
you know loved his swing your own up
um man that's crazy Altuve
I liked uh yeah I mean just just a ton
of guys who uh were any of the none of
those guns were the yeah so who is at
the All-Star Game
I mean Freddy did you get the target
ready a little bit he probably didn't
say much did he he offered me some
cookies that sounds about like Freddy he
eats cookies before the games every game
I mean
[Music]
he goes in there and his sliders and he
gets a couple cookies 20 minutes before
the game takes a couple flips and then
he goes gets three knocks yeah I mean
it's it's unbelievable what he does so
you got the flavor Fred you got to talk
to Freddy and and
be at home and did you stay home or did
you stay at the hotel sit at the hotel I
mean it was kind of a busy schedule but
uh after the game uh went back home and
um you know took an extra day there and
then flew to Toronto after that and then
okay so and then so let's let's switch
gears so
you're amongst the fastest guys in the
leagues
and you've always been fast like did you
have to ever train did you ever train
track or train anything of that nature
is just kind of natural so I did cross
country growing up cross-cut I was I
always thought of myself as more like a
long distance guy
um and then you know come High School
um you know wanted to focus in on
baseball and was like hey maybe you know
some some shorter stuff might be a
little more conducive to this and
started training a little bit more like
sprinting and then did you know you were
as fast as you are or did it just kind
of happen like oh I didn't know I was
this fast because you're running long
distance so you never really got to top
speed unless you just run in top speed
long this and that's yeah that's crazy
no I mean I
I always knew I could run for sure
um
but
I don't think I necessarily knew
um
you were this fast yeah I just knew how
how I stacked up I'd say and do you
think you I mean I do you think if you
Ellie De La Cruz Bobby Witt
you guys race who wins
I don't know I mean come on bro no I
don't know I might say a name dog Ellie
you Bobby
so I saw I saw Ellie play this year
I actually played with Bobby growing up
um a little bit
that's a tough one
but I might have to I might let you talk
about it I'm gonna have to go Ellie oh
you can go with Ellie yeah I I think he
hit a triple on us
and I want to say he took like 20
strides total I mean he was just and he
was just gaining so much ground every
every stride he just runs with Grace and
he's flying yeah I can't say the same
about you because the way you run it's
not it looks like it hurt no you know
you got your chest down it looked like
you run across country but you you're
just running right there though you know
you're running 90 feet yeah no we got um
I mean we got a bunch of fast guys on
the D-backs but we're all a little uh
shorter in stature yeah and so we're all
like that's what they were going for
we're all arguing about Ellie we're like
man it's on fairies guys got everything
he's a fast and Tall yeah he's good he's
got it all so I heard there's a story
about um
you and Dre Jameson you guys raced and
he beat you oh yeah he flies oh he can
run he was gonna uh he was gonna pinch
run for us this year oh so he's that
fast yeah yeah he flies I mean he's
being you he's got to be there so was
were you trying were you like I just
woke up and rolled out of bed and didn't
even warm up no I'm not I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna throw any contacts in
there just he you got me that's that's a
very nice way to not to to
say you rolled out of bed and didn't
stretch or nothing
shout out to you dog you're looking out
for your boy man so no he flies though
me plus you think you could beat the
freeze
we just watched that too about what two
weeks ago I think you could beat him
that's a long run too yeah so if you ran
long distance someone was saying
he uh he's like a D3 national champion
and so I'm gonna go I'm gonna guess now
you're gonna guess no yeah I mean he
okay there he is yeah that's that's it's
super impressive what he does I I enjoy
I've only got to seen it see it like
twice
and he just gets it seems like he gets
faster and then maintains his speed
where everyone kind of loses speed you
know that's so yeah the time we were
there I think we were there about three
three am's and did they did they win one
guy one guy was 10 feet away from the
line and had him and tripped and fell oh
man I feel like when that goes on
everybody stops and watches it oh yeah
yeah there's no Outfield heroes or
anything yeah everybody just stops and
watches it so let's go back to your
journey bro bro so you were 13
and you played infield too you played
info come like and you're left-handed so
how was that like was that fun was it
hard yeah I liked it caught I mean yeah
I did I caught I played Short
um
and I got for All Stars for 12 of you I
mean that's the World Series here right
so I got a little uh I got the thing
from the short with the throat so I
moved the second moved the second so how
are you trying to double play
how was that happening uh or you just
didn't turn double place
I mean just gotta be an athlete yeah
yeah you just figure it out good for you
so you left-handed plane second blade
second base playing short leading off
I think so leading off hidden dingers
yeah so you've been doing this your
whole life and so and then you moved to
the Outfield
and
do you think do you think you could play
short in the big leagues first of all
those guys hit the ball way too hard
they hit it hard in there I mean we've
got we've got some pretty good defensive
shortstops on our club and I'm like
let's let's leave it let's leave it to
them so when when did you move to the
Outfield like was it
um yeah like 13 14. oh yeah because
left-handed yeah you can't play first
base because you know I played a little
bit of first yeah that was like 13 and
14 I was like first and Center
first and Center so I've got all sorts
of gloves in my house I've got the
catching glove the first base glove and
so when you go home do you get to do you
ever or in spring training do you ever
mess around with the other positions no
no it's over with yeah I always joke
with the guys though that I'm gonna
you know put on another 40 pounds and go
grab that First Base Glove one there
it's gonna be a small Target but hey
it's a Target nonetheless right
so oh I got a fact you went to you went
to the same high school as Bill Gates
yeah so who right now not actually in 10
years who do you think the most famous
not richest because we know that that's
well in his bag
the most famous alumni from from your
school
you think you can you think you think
it's you
I mean I mean Bill Gates is Bill Gates
but I'm trying to think who else we got
we got the uh
the actor that that played Batman we got
him I don't know his name but I know
you're talking about he got the deep
voice
man but hey Batman oh he's uh and it's
more he play is it Heath Ledger or
something like that I can look it up but
uh trying to think I forgot what his
name oh Christian Christian Christian
Christian uh Christian Veil it was like
an older it was like the original Batman
I don't know were you around
what are you sure no yeah
um well I mean Michael Michael you don't
even know the name huh no I don't know
not a movie guy yeah you're not a movie
guy yeah and you you were only two when
it came out you ran
a 40 in high school as well and and
in in shoes and you ran a four or five
yeah this is by hand yes by hand so that
means it's slow
because ain't nobody you know I'm
thinking they probably started a split
second slow and ended a split second
slow unless you know so that means four
or five you really ran like a I'm gonna
give you like a 4-4 in tennis shoes
yeah we we also that's another debate
we'll have is like what can we run the
40 in now
um and you got to be faster now than
that
yeah I mean
that that was fun that was freshman year
High School freshman year in high school
I was around four or five yeah you're
going into freshmere I guess um so you
football tryouts right yeah and uh we're
a little late a little late getting
there a little traffic I'm freaking out
I'm like Mom can't be late on the first
day and uh did she did she give you a
hug when you when you went to tryouts
too no no it was run out of the car
Sprint over to the field you know uh
throw on the or I must already had
tennis shoes on oh so you were already
you were already loose because you the
adrenaline was like a year late
and ran it and then did you make it just
based off that you made the team yeah I
told they said what I mean we we weren't
the most competitive football team oh
okay okay so uh they're they're kind of
just like what do you what position do
you play yeah what was this one did you
and so I said I said quarterback and
cornerback and so quarterback and
cornerback so I I went for it yeah
quarterback though yeah so
did you play quarterback I I played so
freshman year I played JV and then I'd
play a little bit in Varsity quarterback
yeah
genuine question yeah
well not not maybe not if y'all were
that good how did you
how did you see you know like did you
did you see that no where you just you
just hoped they were there and threw it
no not even that it was immediate
I can't see anything let's go try and
get outside the pocket and and then
we'll we'll reassess from there but yeah
and that was with the high school line
right I mean we've got we've got Kyler
here and AZ yeah
I mean he's got that's crazy he's got
grown man yeah he's he's doing something
no but I'm talking about you because in
eighth grade I mean ninth grade how how
many years did you play football just
one just one so you play your freshman
year yeah
you had to be little yeah I mean I was
five six five six probably what
130 130 pounds yeah not not big
and what could you hold could you grip
the football were you strong enough to
grip the football and launch that thing
or I mean the Thrills were not the
throws were subpar the running was my
game Run I mean
good so and why why didn't you why'd you
stop playing
um I think just uh
what after yeah after freshman year I
that was kind of when uh baseball got a
little more serious it was like Hey you
know these colleges are offering you
already yeah after after freshman summer
after freshman summer
you were getting offers yeah yeah
um I think maybe they've changed the
rules a little bit now but where it's
like it has to be a little later but I
think that was you know for some of the
better players that was you know
um
you know not not abnormal so for those
of you out there who don't get the
offers after your freshman year
that was me
they they took it all the way they did
it right I was a junior
and I got a couple calls
it's okay you have time
not everybody's Corbin Carroll
anyways so so you got called you got how
is that getting attention like that
immediately I mean
what what was what did you do when
you're getting these offers or talking
to these coaches I mean you're five six
130 pounds you know you don't know what
you're doing I mean you know you're
balling but you don't really know
you know what's going on in life so how
do you how did you accept all that yeah
and you know I got um they got some of
the best parents in the world okay so
they yeah yeah
so they uh you know they kept me you
know straight and uh
you know just
kept kept me grounded and kept me you
know here what are your priorities
um so the coaches talk to your parents a
lot no no they wanted yeah they talked
to me um that was a big thing like my
parents were like they want to get to
know you
um so you know you're gonna be the one
communicating with them but just uh all
sorts of advice you know like just some
different things to think about
um it definitely helped me and continue
to this day to uh just kind of think
think the right way and then you
committed to go to UCLA yeah
what made you want to go there
uh the coaches I mean that's really what
I figured it out
um where did you really want to go to
school
so I mean growing up USC was my dream oh
nice okay that was where you know pops
went that was where my my long my coach
growing up went
um but
yeah they weren't too interested wow
so so you ended up UCL or you signed to
go to UCLA and then you got drafted
and
you got drafted and said you felt like
you were going to be a ranger
yeah I did what what tell take me
through your mind
how you just say I'm gonna be a ranger
like you know what what was it did you
want to or did you know what was it
behind the ranger where did Ranger come
into play yeah so we had um or I was
fortunate enough to do some of the the
USA baseball stuff
um just the 18-year and uh you know our
director of baseball for that
um ended up going over to the Rangers
and uh
you know it was kind of just like hey
I'm gonna vouch for you like you're
you're my guy hey that's what he said
yeah and so that that was part of it
um you know I'd had someone I'd known
growing up in the Northwest
um
that was over there too and it was like
Hey like you know there might be a shot
um so just that you were cool with it
you were like yeah I want to go to I
want to go to yeah I guess you know it
wasn't just like you didn't care yeah I
had grandparents in Texas
um so I was like all right like at least
so you was envisioned in Texas in your
head just just if you had to ask if you
if I had to give my best guess that
would have been my guess I'm going into
it and then when you got drafted to the
D-backs
were you like what you know what was
your were you just grateful at that
point were you like man I wanted to go
to the Rangers no no I wasn't like that
at all um and not in a bad way yeah yeah
yeah right you know
I was I was pumped you were excited yeah
so it didn't really matter you just the
ranger was like that would have been
that would have been a cool little thing
because you would have known some people
yeah it was more just uh I think I think
the way I got asked was like where
where'd you think that you were gonna go
oh okay so I was like that's why that's
working yeah I didn't
it didn't uh you know I didn't have too
many like preferences there so and then
you got drafted and you're playing go
through minor league ball how was the
minor leagues for you
um it was good it was it was weird
um you know I didn't have
you know the most typical minor league
experience I I played my first half
season in 19 uh at 20 we had covid 21 I
played Seven games and then got hurt the
rest of the year yeah so tell me about
that you you hurt your shoulder yeah on
a swing
Homer though homer so shoulder went down
a champ yeah okay so we had three first
rounders in a row
all blow out their shoulders so I did it
on the swing one of them did a dive and
one of them did it in BP same year uh no
uh just in general yeah it was 2019 2021
and 2022.
so at least I did it the best way right
yeah yeah
so and then you you're going through the
rehab
and you go take some classes at ASU yeah
what made you want to do that
um
why I started it up during during covid
got bored um boredom boredom strikes
again yeah boredom made you got bored
instead of saying you know what I'ma
find a hobby or or
go do something you said I want to go to
school yeah yeah good for you you know
education has always been important to
to me and uh you know I just
my family stuck me in some some pretty
you know some nice schools and so I
thought it'd be a good way to show them
how much I appreciated that and uh so
I'd started during covid and then 2021
uh yeah the shoulders injury and I was
like all right like I can kind of keep
this going so end up getting about two
two years in so you're two years in
right now yeah and then do you plan on
finishing the last two years so
I would have gone back fall of 22 fall
of last year
but I was like hey maybe there's a
chance I get called up
um and so I've been doing it at ASU and
uh their school starts in
like middle of August and last year with
a lot the lockout and everything the
season went late I think it went into
November yeah and so I didn't know if I
want to do a month and a half of school
with well possibly you know first big
league experience
um so it's been on hold so that means no
that's what I'm hearing because I mean
you got you got ball and I'm sure school
will be it's gonna be awesome right it's
gonna be awesome to have that degree
um but
I don't think you're gonna need it we'll
see we'll see give me a couple years
we'll see now
like I said
sign the you signed the deal so when you
were negotiating back and forth
how was that or was it fun was it
stressful because that's a lot of money
and you know people don't
realize you know
it's hard to just say no to 50 million
dollars right
when you're going back and forth
especially in your rookie you're young
you don't even really know how the
business works
and now you're getting an extension
how was that how was that process tell
me about your parents too because you
know I'm sure they had a big say-so in
this
actually a little less probably than you
think I kind of wanted to keep
um there was just a lot going on right
first spring training like trying to
make the club
um then this contract extension stuff
and then just trying to be you know a
normal person and have those
relationships away from from the field
and so I kind of
um kept that more between me and my
agent
um
but
I wouldn't say too stressful it was
pretty pretty simple in my mind of it's
just it's it's either going to be yes or
no it is what it is it's going to make
sense or it isn't and um
you know just every night
um would hop on the phone with the agent
for about about an hour
um you know might end up being a little
longer a little shorter depending on the
day but
um just
that felt good to be that involved
um it made me feel like we'd exhausted
every opportunity and uh in every
structure every you know length
um to kind of find something that
that made sense to both sides and what
about the Diamondbacks made
you want to you know you know made you
assign the extension because obviously
it's a great organization you got Tori
who I know and love
and and the front office I think they
drafted me yeah so you got a great crew
around you right but what outside of
that what about the Diamondbacks made
you say you know what I can be here for
a while yeah I love AZ
um I love I love being here
hot like this
I mean we play inside it's all good yeah
you're right you're right you're right
um but it it really came down to the
people for me I feel like we've got a
special group of people
um
you know this
even I'd say especially during my injury
um and just kind of the care and and
just genuineness that people showed me
whether it was in the front office
whether it was Tori shooting me a call
or popping over to the complex and
checking on us
um just the things like that as well as
as the players like you said you know I
played with the minor leagues and really
got to see you know the level of talent
that we have
um it was
it made me feel good okay so what was
the first thing you bought when when you
uh after you signed
uh
trying to think
so opening opening weekend you're
opening week whatever it was in in LA
right we went over to the the jewelry
store with with uh a buddy out there and
I got a little necklace got a little
necklace you wear it do you you wear it
every day or yeah I got it on right now
yeah well nice little man that ain't
little
oh nice yeah don't don't tuck it in
leave it out
no we Debo ain't coming he ain't gonna
come take your chain man like yeah you
can leave it out but uh no I mean it's
cool so you got that and you haven't
gotten anything else yeah I mean it's
been something I've been I want a little
necklace for for a little while in a
couple years and was like all right
let's let's let's do it did you get your
mom or dad or you got a brother sister
yeah your sister a younger sister you
get your sister anything
uh oh yeah I could tell by the way you
look yeah I got your sister done man so
uh
how I don't know if I want to put this
out hopefully she doesn't hear this but
no she's gonna hear it she's gonna hear
I I tried I tried to get her a car uh
and my parents said no oh
I said uh yeah sorry sis it's coming
though you know whenever mom and dad say
yeah yeah I mean how ridiculous is that
no they said that's crazy yeah they said
she's got you know she's got a good
thing going she's she's super hard
working how old is she she's seven or
eighteen I just turned eighteen yeah
um but so
she's uh gonna play some soccer in
college like is she fast does she yeah
she flies Angie Stall oh and she's tall
where did that okay so that's six four
oh dang he just skipped you
man I got screwed huh duh yeah it's all
right I mean you play big though you you
you play big and you know but that's all
you just played like that you just don't
look like that we're both little you
know but so she's tall yeah and she run
fast
left footed left left so everybody's
left-handed in in around the family yeah
from my mom's side yeah okay so and
she's a soccer player she's gonna go
play soccer in college and is she on the
team you is she was she getting calls
when she was a freshman and everything
too no no she uh she I'd say develops a
little later okay um so she's normal
yeah she's normal good for her I want to
meet your sister one day sister come to
the game please I want to shake your
hand say hi look up and say hi you know
where I'm looking at Corbin we're
looking kind of eye level but look up
and say hi I want to meet your parents
too whenever they come man they seem
like some uh some super dope people
um I do want to kind of ask them
not to be mad at you for not see since
they didn't since you didn't really use
them in the contract negotiations
you know because you probably you didn't
really think that
I'm gonna be here with you and we in L.A
you know we balling in L.A you know so
you're gonna have to come through us you
know we're gonna have some battles for
the next eight years and then after that
we'll see you I'm gonna be on my way out
yeah yeah I love that though that's good
it's gonna be awesome
I think you know
AZ maybe a little smaller market right I
think we're maybe we're balling yeah
we're we're you know the a little bit of
that Underdog right I like I like being
the I like being on it yeah I like being
well in that position look I'ma just
tell you we ain't gonna make it easy so
you're gonna have to come fall which you
always do
so I um
you you done Immaculate grid
I've tried to help out some friends I've
never done it myself but before we get
into the immaculate grid
there was something that happened the
other day
you don't have to make that face because
you don't have to think about it as soon
as I say something you're gonna know
exactly what I'm talking about
in Cleveland
oh yeah
there was a uh a bra that kind of went
on and to me
you know when you're playing a sport
trying to feed your family
you're around the boys all day every day
for eight months including spring
training
you know things just kind of boil or it
could be anything right somebody just
accidentally trip you and it could be
guys could be having a bad day you never
know
and so
uh that happened and
that was kind of crazy I I would have
been the Umpire the Umpire he started in
there named Matt he started in there and
he backed out of there he was out of
there quick
you guys can have it that's what I would
have did you know but I did want to just
say like
you know things like that happen man and
it is TA is my boy T.A me ta is really
my boy and
he got him you know what I'm saying he
just got God you know sometimes it is
what it is and it is but
you know that I think it's just really
just things kind of just boiled over and
somebody's probably just having a bad
day and I know you don't have to we had
a team meeting about it oh you guys had
a team meeting yeah so I mean you don't
have to give me all the details about
the team meeting but like give me
something about the meeting players only
oh nice okay yeah tell me basically
you don't tell me we said that we said
if if someone gets knocked out on the
field there is no way that there's not
enough nothing thrown after that oh I
mean no no one fought after yeah that
was kind of just yeah they kind of stood
around they did yeah you got to protect
your boy right you do got to protect
your boy and
you know if there's a fight that breaks
out with us
I love us I love you guys I love you
guys to death
I don't I'm just gonna be pulling people
out of there don't expect me to come
throw elbows punch I'm just not made
like that all right so so that's that's
our agreement if we ever brawl we'll
come hold each other back
truce
all right so
now let's get to the immaculate grid on
a lighter note
um you've done it before you're young
but you're a baseball you're a baseball
fan though so you should know some of
them I'd say I'd say my knowledge here
is about as good as my my movie
knowledge
so you might be interested you went to
college though so I mean you went to
costume you got more more knowledge now
right I don't know if that
correlates at all but that's just my
thought I know the first might be bad
Bartolo Colon is the first one
Rangers
and
and blue jays
Rangers and blue jays I feel like I know
that
I want to say uh 20 plus Seasons oh
Verlander for
Detroit and that's oh Utah Martin
Detroit Mets yeah you can do Verlander
for the second one
yep Verlander for the second one under
under I'm sorry under
and then to the right
who played with Toronto I mean we just
talked about all that fight all I'm
thinking about is Jose Bautista right
now he played with tech did he play well
that was that was the brawl oh yeah that
was mean that was nasty too I didn't
know I didn't know baseball players had
Haymakers like that man see night that's
why I'm staying out of there too because
you don't never know who gonna be you
know throwing punches like that
um
let's go with the LA uh 25 is Cole
Hamels Cole Hamels you think is that a
uh 20 did he ever have 20 wins with the
with Texas I mean
I'm trying to think of all the pictures
with Texas and I'm sure there's a I'm
Nolan Ryan Maybe
uh yeah he had to have right
nope
what about uh 20 wins yeah Nolan Ryan
didn't he play with Texas what about Tom
Tom Seaver Tom Ford maybe I don't know
I'm not a foreign
Tom Seaver for the last guy on the on
the left column yeah I'm not like a I'm
a basketball guy so uh I'm doing these
this is actually teaching me a lot about
all right all right baseball so you just
taught me something Tom Seaver see
that's college you want the ASU shout
out to ASU for uh teaching him
some knowledge some baseball knowledge
yeah what uh 20 wins I'm trying
Toronto and Detroit
who played with Toronto and the I don't
I don't know none of these
200ks in this season
I mean the Blue Jays aren't that old I
feel like I know I want us
and I remember looking up and seeing all
the names up there
oh I can't I can't remember the names
because it's been like five years five
or six years since I've been to
Toronto
we're trash yeah three three out of nine
that's tough my yeah you said it though
my high school character's gonna be mad
at me for this one yeah he normally gets
eight out of nine eight out of nine yeah
he's good enough thanks sorry High
School coach you know we we tried man my
high school coach he would probably be
mad at me too because he could do all
these but um sorry sorry man we we tried
we tried coach yeah can we take the grid
off that's embarrassing that's
embarrassing
we're gonna go to the next thing what
about uh so now I got some fan questions
bro before we rap
I got some fan questions
um
for Corbin each Rose your favorite
player who's your the Mount Rushmore of
Outfitters of all time for you of all
time of all time
oh man
I mean I feel like you gotta go
mantle
uh maze
this might be a two-person Mountain
Rushmore
mantle and Maze
who else
I mean is Ichiro not on there who's your
favorite player I mean he's on mine
that's what I'm asking yours okay yeah
Ichiro
and trout
that's a good that that's a good and you
know what's crazy is the fact that you
said trout that lets me know how young
you are that is crazy good for you Mikey
you made it all right so
another another fan says I love the
Diamondbacks fits what's your what's
your favorite uniform combination that
you guys have so we got the uh we got
the Pinstripe purple purple teal coming
back oh okay let's get that uh what I
think the Padres Series this weekend
they're bringing it out is it just a a
throwback or yeah yeah but I love those
Unis and so I like you guys as a
serpentes okay uh jerseys they get some
hate sometimes but I'm with you I like
them too
I I really I really do like those series
I like uh
and I like the uh do you guys have the
the vest anymore do you wear the vest
anymore that's the one that's oh that's
the same one okay that's the same one
okay that's gonna be super dope so I got
one more question
would you rather
would you rather shave all your hair
or lose all your teeth
it's got to be the hair right hair's got
it it's Gotta Be hair's gotta go
I mean I couldn't even imagine having
think about it you haven't there's so
many more problems yeah you can't what
can you eat can't talk
I don't know what else you could do I
mean but you would look good I mean you
can't smile so yeah you wouldn't look
good you wouldn't be nothing
I mean gums or
could you get could you get some fake
teeth though yeah but that that that
would that wouldn't be would you rather
you know yeah yeah you know so you only
got one all right yeah it's got to be
the hair yeah it got to be the hair so
we're gonna get ready to Rap Man I thank
you for coming on
um you know the super dope
super super good to see like young guys
the head on their shoulders doing things
the right way you guys are playing the
game the right way you're leading the
team
um even though you guys are so young I
know you got like Christian Walker in
there with guys that have been around
for a while but you know you're a very
very important piece of this
Diamondbacks team and
it's good for you to know that and I
think you already do know that and
embrace it because the hard part that I
had to learn
is
being good and embracing it a lot of
people are good and they say nah you
know I'm not that good or nah you know
it's not about me it's about the team it
is about the team right but also you
know you got to play well in order for
the team to be doing well and this is
kind of a fact it's just and the more
you Embrace that
the better you'll be over a longer
period of time the more consistent
you'll because it just puts you in a
different mind yeah that's that's good
advice and you know def just want to
take a moment to to appreciate the fact
that like
you know 14 15 year old Corbin would be
um just freaking out if you knew that
you know he'd be here talking to you
um you know sitting here as you know
somewhat of peers
um and so I just want to appreciate that
yeah of course
of course man of course man again
let me know when your folks are coming I
want to meet them they seem like some
awesome people tell your mom
if she can
we stay at
right the hotel I would like to get
dropped off too
just Mom please come drop me off too and
so I've been looking forward to hearing
from you mom dad and sister corbs he
gonna be running long distance to the
stadium so I will see you there and uh
that's a wrap guys we'll see catch you
guys next time
thank you
[Music]